when the credits roll at the end of
MORTAL KOMBAT 11 story mode the slate
has been wiped clean after a variety of
time-travel hijinks everyone's second
favorite Shaolin monk Liu Kang has
ascended into godhood and is ready to
begin writing an all new chapter in
Mortal Kombat history it's as close to a
perfect ending as you can get to the
almost 30 years of convoluted law this
series has but now there's aftermath
Mortal Kombat Elevens optional expansion
that tacks on a handful of new chapters
to that narrative and while the idea of
a story focus to add on to this fighting
game is an exciting prospect and it
certainly has its high moments when the
credits roll for the second time there
isn't that same sense of gratification
[Applause]
at the beginning of aftermath which
immediately follows the end of Mortal
Kombat xi Liu Kang is interrupted by the
nefarious sorceress Shang Tsung along
with the righteous wind-god Fujin and
the badass indigenous shaman nightwolf
the trio stops Liu Kang from proceeding
with his rebuilding plans with the
warning that they need to go back in
time again to retrieve him MacGuffin in
order to stop the process I'm going to
share over five chapters and a cinema
appropriate to point five our running
time the five Mortal Kombat characters
that have now been introduced to MK 11
as posed to release content get to make
their mark in the story the chapters
covered the hijinks of Shang Tsung
Nightwolf and the Banshee Queen Sindel
from the fighters Pack 1 DLC as well as
two characters newly introduced in
aftermath Fujin and the four armed Shiva
[Music]
the relatively brief running time of the
whole thing allows it to be mostly
filled with great moments the
blockbuster flare present in the
original story mode is again in full
force as is the excellent fight
choreography that makes you want to leap
out of your chair there's still that we
disconnect when an extravagant fight
cinematic transitions into the more
rigid nature of the game's actual
one-on-one fights but there are some
good moments that lie in the gameplay
portions too like the handful of battles
where you have an assist character to
call on the absolute highlight of the
story and probably the whole optimal
package is undoubtedly Kari Hiroyuki
Takaya as performance as he reprises
shang tsung he is deliciously evil and
the fact that he knows that every other
character is incredibly wary of his
inevitable betrayal Billy feeds his
playfully arrogant eager great facial
animations and expressions along with
the amusingly unscrupulous Tambor of his
voice helped to really nail key moments
here his sly smirking grin definitely
left a big impression on me why are we
listening to this snake secret I know
them Shang Tsung is an absolute treasure
and the overall story is mostly
entertaining all the way through my
exception is Shiva's chapter in which
the plot barely moves forward but I
couldn't help but feel a bit ambivalent
when it was all said and done since the
story essentially leaves the series law
in the same place that's a big relief in
a way and I'm glad the five new
characters managed to get some time the
spotlight I mean this is a great roster
but that comes at the cost of taking
away some of the grand prospects of
endless possibility that we were left
with last time a new ending teaser
definitely seems to narrow the scope
someone superfluous story aside the
other content included in the aftermath
expansion are three new characters the
aforementioned Shiva and Fujin as well
as special guest character Robocop from
the classic 1987 former urban film which
is the only Robocop movie that exists as
far as I know Shiva is a heavy-hitting
grappler with some great advancing
options best characterized by her flying
stomp where she disappears off the
screen before crashing down on her
opponent fujian is an incredibly flashy
and unique art
who is excellent at controlling space
with ricocheting crossbow bolts the
ability to push and pull his opponents
all over the place with the power of
wind and he also has the delightful
ability to run through the air and
strike from above I love both of these
new characters though your enjoyment may
vary depending on your preferred play
style Robocop on the other hand I didn't
quite gel with he's a keep away
character who merely focuses on keeping
his opponents at bay with a number of
projectile and knock-back options a
style that feels in line with the
character it can be a killer strategy if
you have the patience and the ability to
read your opponent's movements well but
it's unfortunately not something that I
excel at and as a result I didn't find
Robocop to be as interesting of a
character movie or Marge's aside the
release of aftermath also sees Mortal
Kombat 11 get a major update that adds
new brutality finishes for every
character new stages as well as the
introduction of some stage specific
fatalities and friendship finishes the
retro arcade stage in which in in
universe projector beams out classic
mortal combat stages accompanied by a
period appropriate soundtrack is one of
my personal favorites but friendships of
a significant new addition instead of
finishing your opponent by mutilating
them each character now has the option
to show off their playful side with
bizarre performances of unabashed joy
though some are certainly a lot more
inspired than others
Jax's saxophone solo is a clear
front-runner in Schenck songs rainbow
garden is on the other end of the scale
it's a little terrifying to see the
Mortal Kombat characters smile so hard
but overall they're definitely a
worthwhile inclusion
but the friendships new stages and all
of that other stuff is freely available
for owners of MORTAL KOMBAT 11 and the
only content exclusive to aftermath are
the additional story chapters and three
new characters though that's a very
welcome decision free is good it makes
aftermath less compelling when
considered specifically on its own terms
Mortal Kombat 11 remains one of the best
fighting games of this console
generation and the recent update makes
it better after mass introduces a couple
of great characters and expanded story
definitely has its highs but it's not
essential to your enjoyment of an
already superb game
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]